FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Let me show you how
to add cloud endpoints
to an existing app engine
flexible environment
application.
First of all, let's try running
the application locally.
It is a simple echo
server [? run in ?] go,
so we can run it with Go Run.
Now we can verify that
everything works correctly,
sending a post
request with Curl.
To deploy the
application, we first
configure the project
at [INAUDIBLE] cloud.
And then we run aedeploy,
gcloud app deploy.
The aedeploy part is needed
only for go applications.
After a short period of time,
the application is deployed,
and we can test it
again using Curl.
Great, let's add some
cloud endpoints now.
We will need an open APS
specification of our API.
In our case, it's
a very simple one.
One single path that
replies to a post request
with the same
message it receives.
We can now deploy
that specification
to cloud endpoints with
these gcloud command.
As a result, we will
receive a cloud endpoints
name and a configuration ID.
We now add those two
values to our app.yaml,
and we deploy application.
Open API is an open
standard, which
means all the tools
developed for open API
are now available for you
to use with cloud endpoints.
For instance, if you
get your specification
and put it in
editor.swagger.io, you
can't see the autogenerated
documentation, which
is incredibly useful
for the developers,
and, also, you can even run
the application directly here
by saying, hello,
running that request,
and getting the response.
Great, right?
Now that we have
deployed our application
and the corresponding
open API specification,
we get to enjoy
monitoring and logging.
We can fake some traffic and see
how the graphics react to it,
or go see how the logs
appear in real time.
OK, one last thing,
let's secure our API
so only calls with an API
key will be authorized.
We do not need to
change our code just
to add a security
definition on our open API
specification and redeploy.
Let's test it with Curl now.
Without the API key,
our request is rejected.
But with the correct API
key, everything works fine.
So there you go, with a
simple open APS specification
and cloud endpoint, we
get monitoring, logging,
and authentication,
and the possibility
of using all the tools that
already exist for the open API
ecosystem.